- On Sean's show he has a
game called truth or dab,
in which guests either answer tough,
sometimes embarrassing questions
or eat a very hot hot wing.
- Oh!
- So I'm planning on
being super truthful Rita.
Because Rita and I are
- Okay, I don't know.
- Masochistic we thought, what the hell,
let's give it a try,
challenge accepted Sean
- Go for it.
- All right well welcome to a very special
daytime addition of truth or dab,
the Hot Ones special
where we give our guests
two simple options, tell the truth
or suffer the wrath of the last dab.
Today though, mercifully,
we're using Los Calientes Rojo
- Mercifully?
- Mercifully.
- This is probably going
to be so hot to me.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So it's tell the truth,
or suffer the wrath of
a pretty spicy wing.
And I'm thrilled to be here
on the Kelly Clarkson Show.
With Kelly Clarkson
(audience cheers)
and Rita Wilson in front of you,
you guys have three wings
- I can smell it.
- that have all been doused.
- [Kelly] I can smell the heat.
- In very hot sauce.
- I don't know why you
being like, oh we're nice,
I can smell the heat.
- It's like there's a
mirage coming off of this.
You can see the little waves.
- And we haven't even started yet.
- I'm so nervous Sean, go.
- I have a set of deeply personal,
potentially awkward questions for you.
- [Together] Okay.
- And when I read you a
question, you have a choice.
Answer it honestly, or escape the truth,
by eating a wing.
- I am super truthful.
(audience laughs)
- Well we'll see how
truthful Kelly is here,
'cause we're gonna
- Yes you will.
- start with you Kelly.
- Fine.
- Oh my god.
- Name one song, from
a fellow Voice judge,
that you hope you never
have to hear again.
(audience moans)
- Okay now this is not
because it's not a great song,
it's because we ruined it
by playing it too much.
I love you John Legend, I love All of Me,
but I need a minute, I need a minute.
I don't want to hear it for
a minute, just a minute.
(audience cheers)
And then I'll be fine, I'll be fine.
I don't want that hot wing.
I'm risking our friendship,
'cause I don't want that.
You go.
- All right Rita, on to you
- God, she's passing.
Okay.
- What's the best lie
you ever got away with.
- Oh, oh no, you better eat that.
You aint gonna tell us, you
aint gonna tell us (laughs).
- [Sean] Rita's looking at me.
- [Kelly] That one was harder!
(audience cheers)
- Help me lord.
- She was giving me the eyes,
like that was a set up.
- I am sweating for you.
- I'm actually afeared right now.
- I know, I am too.
- Okay, ready?
- [Sean] Hey, let's make
some noise for Rita.
(audience cheers)
- Is it doable?
Oh no oh no.
Is it doable?
Oh my mouth is watering, I'm so scared.
- It kind of gets hotter
as you start eating it.
- Oh god, oh god, oh my god.
- There's a build on there
and you'll see we do have
some safety nets here.
- Oh wow, oh wow.
- You have great producers here
at the Kelly Clarkson show.
You have some honey, we have
some lemon, we have some bread.
Rita, diving into the milk.
- [Kelly] Yeah oh my gosh.
- When you swallow it, it gets really hot!
And it stays there.
(audience laughs)
- And it stays there.
You know what, still burning,
still burning my esophagus.
- It's still burning
- I'm so glad I got my question.
- You know what, the questions
just keep coming though.
- [Rita] It's not over Kelly.
- I know, I'm so ready.
- Who was the worst interview
on your show so far.
(audience moans)
(audience chanting)
- I cannot tell the truth,
'cause my show just started
and I don't want to piss people off.
So, this way do I start here?
- Yup.
- Okay, aw man.
(Rita laughs)
(audience cheers)
Oh my god, it is so hot.
You are used to hot
- Yes
- I am not used to hot.
- No wait, it gets hotter.
- [Kelly] No way!
- Yes wait till you swallow it
- Oh my god you can feel it
in your nostrils, you can
feel it in your nostrils.
- Unchartered territory here.
- Oh my god, okay, everything is fine.
Is this helpful?
(audience laughs)
- You've got V8, you tell me.
(Kelly gargles)
(audience laughs)
- Wait, I want to try that.
Hold on a second.
- Oh my god.
- All right Rita while you sip that down,
(both gargle)
let me ask you this,
- Get it in there, oh my
god my mouth is on fire.
You said this was mild.
(Kelly screams)
- It has an after burn.
- Okay, I'm so ready.
- Rita, if you could take
one credit off your resume,
what would it be and why?
- I know mine "From Justin to Kelly".
(all laugh)
Contractually obligated Rita.
- That is so good.
- Okay I think it might be the movie
that haunts me every Christmas,
"Jingle All the Way".
- No!
Now that's wrong,
that's a great classic.
- That's a classic,
that's a classic.
- Wait you have to
understand, I love the movie.
But I don't understand my character in it
because why does my
character not understand
that Turbo Man is her husband?
Like how many superheros sound
like Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Like how dumb is my
character, like I don't know.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- It's till the end of the
movie, when she's like,
he reveals himself, and
she goes, "Howard?".
(audience laughs)
"Howard."
Hello she didn't know?
- First of all,
that was sexy.
- No.
- Yes.
- Get it Tom!